what's up I'm Ryan Beck and I'm a
cluster fest and I'm gonna do everything
in my power to get Steven Jacobs from
Third Eye Blind mm my dog
I'm doing is here Ryan yeah we got a
boom it's out of frame yeah we got a
puppy let's make some basic cable it'll
be on the Internet
I'm Ryan back I'm here at clustered
festival in my all-time favorite
musician Steven Jenkins a Third Eye
Blind not true it's true man its first
CD I ever bought I don't wanna tell you
because I felt like yeah it's important
not to talk it out yeah well anyway this
is Bruce Bruce she's a sweet girl she is
a rescue dog she is a rocket dog rescue
and when I got her she had mange and
worms she had an ear infection she with
malnutrition she was just beat to
well cuz I wanted a boy but but girls
are better cuz when you stroke their
belly there's not all that annoying dick
in the way that's true my dog's a girl
and she's also a rescue and I think I
have a picture here some oh yeah here we
go
Wow Lilly's so cute - its fake she's
home alone right now
and all she has is my girlfriend and my
girlfriend's parents and her sister and
some dog walkers and some other family
friends with her it's like any youth I
know and so I know she's really missing
me and probably feels really isn't give
a damn no man she's my god come on I
don't have any musical talent I can't
play instruments and people generally
just don't respect me so I run this song
from the perspective of my dog Lily's
ballad yeah it's for it's her song that
she feels when she's alone and you want
me to sing it I would love for you to
sing anything is I'm like high on
antibiotics now because I think I got
bronchitis are you on yeah I'm allergic
to an ox asila it's a pink one so I
think it goes like this where do you go
when you're gone tell me
I think about you even while you are
away where do you go when you're gone
tell me I'll keep your underwear while
you are away it's tough to be a dog when
you're all alone
you only have your toys peanut butter
and a bone
[Music]
okay
door creaks open and much to my
[Music]
at home now
I wanna I wanna have something to draw
just like you know let's come on let's
play name is Bruce tada
that was incredible really great song
thanks Mia you can play it later if you
want I've got it it's all locked in here
is your daughter rescued my dog is a
rescue that's great yeah here's the
thing yeah we both have these like like
lovely happy healthy dogs and they're
both rescues it's really great and easy
and karmically lovely to get a rescue
dog there will be all over your
kitchen for longer than you think it you
can stand but you'll be amazingly what
you can put up with when you cuddle with
them that's the journey in your
kitchen
folks I'm Ryan Beck that's Steven
Jenkins we sang the song thanks for
watching